How often do you need animals? I don't know if I answered this last week or not. How often do you
need to do animals, coffee animals? Really depends on what your purpose is as far as your health
conditions go. So, currently I don't do any coffee animals. If I am feeling ill in a way that I feel
like the cancer is raising its ugly head again, which was a few months ago, I would start
of doing animals I did them for a few days. But again, I wouldn't do coffee animals on a
necessarily on a regular basis if you're in a full revision as far as cancer goes.
Some people understand the purpose of doing a coffee animal. So, the purpose of doing a coffee
animal is to stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system because it stimulates your vagus nerve,
your creatinine nerve 10. So, bagel nerve stimulation stimulates your parasympathetic which helps
stimulate detoxification pathways and can stimulate immune function. So, you don't do a coffee
animal because you're constipated even though you can't do a coffee animal for constipation. But the
purpose of doing a coffee animal is to stimulate your parasympathetics. So, a person that has
is prone to sympathetic overdrive. So, remember, we're talking about sympathetic and parasympathetic,
we're talking about that balance in your autonomic nervous systems. Your autonomic nervous system
is your automatic nervous system that is controlling everything in your body that you don't have to
think about. So, some people are prone to sympathetic overdrive. There can be chemical reasons for that.
Primary is excess glutamate of the brain, but that's another discussion. So, if a person is
prone to sympathetic overdrive, those are people that are more OCD, that are more anxiety-ridden,
coffee animals on a daily basis, even if they don't have any other co-morbid health conditions,
can be extremely beneficial because they are call me because what do they do? They stimulate your
parasympathetics. So, people that are sympathetic driven and tend to be in balance that way,
doing daily coffee animals can be fantastic for them, and they just make them feel better,
takes away their anxiety. Why? Because it's stimulating your parasympathetics. So, there's benefit
to that. So, everybody's different. I have some patients that never do coffee animals that just don't
want to do it. And I have a lot of patients that do them daily, even in full remission that they're
doing great.